And I would say the first one is probably an outlier,
this data point over here seems to be really far away from the other Xs.
This one isn't, it's non-linear, but it seems the data is very, very consistent.
Whereas, here I'd say we do have an outlier because this data point over here
is far away.
This one is interesting, and Katie and I debated it.
You might call it an outlier or not.
I did. And since I do this video, I get to choose.
She didn't.
I would say it's not outliers in space but also in class labels, but it
could also be just a single example of a different class that's not an outlier.
So that's unclear.
This one to me looks more clear, the data point further away.
And a single data point called an outlier is kind of, I don't know, crazy.
So I would never call this thing here an outlier.